[Musique]
aujourd'hui jeudi 13 octobre nouvelle
édition du 7 8 les invités l'actualité
avec celles et ceux qui en sont les
acteurs voci et les titres vous
entendrez aujourd'hui elle nicolas beau
père le conseiller municipal
d'opposition à elancourt a été placé en
retrait de son parti le front national
il vient de passer devant la commission
de discipline on lui reproche des propos
critiques et un soutien dans l'ancien
responsable départemental aujourd'hui
lui aussi écarté en raison d'une
proximité avec jean marie le pen et puis
et grégory jarry astier le maire les
républicains de maurepas nous expliquera
comment il compte agir pour aider le
commerce de proximité sa commune
participé le week-end dernier à la fête
du commerce est une opération nationale
il est aujourd'hui l'ex secrétaire de la
11e circonscription des yvelines pour le
front national mais aussi son ex
trésorier adjoint son ex secrétaire
départemental adjoint et l'ex directeur
de cabinet du maire de manque la ville
nicolas beau père a été placé à l'écart
de son parti il évoque même un
harcèlement il va nous expliquer
pourquoi ce soir bonsoir nicolas
vollaire le soir aujourd'hui le 10
octobre dernier vous êtes passés devant
la commission de discipline du front
national vous attendez encore le verdict
mais finalement quelle que soit la
décision il semble que la rupture est
inévitable pour vous aujourd'hui on veut
tout simplement vous écartez absolument
que je subis un acharnement de la part
de mon parti de la part de l'ancien de
la nouvelle fédération des yvelines
on ma
supprimer mon investiture enfin on a
bien redonné investitures aux
législatives dans l'ancienne problème
législatives a refusé qu'on m'a refusé
bon il n'y avait pas de raison
réel puisque j'étais le seul candidat
dans la 11e ses conceptions à me
présenter comme candidat
étant élu je pensais que c'était tout à
fait logique et que ça allait dans le
sens de la de la méritocratie qui était
le credo de marine le pen bon voilà et
donc j'ai essayé moi de savoir pourquoi
mais on voulait m'écarter et donc j'ai
appelé plusieurs fois le dossier j'ai
essayé d'avoir des personnes qui
pouvaient me répondre et on m'a dit
clairement que
on dit nicolas vous comprenez bien que
on peut pas investir un candidat qui est
en procès avec un maire fn alors il ya
cette situation du droit c'est avec le
maire de mansle je crois à l'évoquer
dans un instant mais jeudi par rapport à
philippe chevrier leur est l'ancien
responsable départemental qui lui a
affiché un soutien à jean marie le pen
notamment est-ce que c'est aussi votre
cas vous le soutenez à philippe chevrier
moi je soutiens philippe chevrier c'est
j'ai travaillé avec lui pendant six ans
dans les yvelines on a fait un travail
qu'ils fassent est lui qui était à
l'origine de ce travail qu'on a fait
avec les résultats qu'on connaît qui est
un très très bon bilan sous le mandat de
philippe chevrier
on était une équipe soudée solidaire
aujourd'hui c'est une chasse aux
sorcières parce que vous soutenez ce
soit vous philippe chevrier jean marie
le pen très clairement oui oui toi une
autre intrigue très très clairement je
veux dire
on le front national vient de recruter
un nettoyeur au front national si vous
avez entendu parler de ça monsieur la
capelle donc son rôle c'est de de virer
les éléments indésirables mais bon moi
j'ai jette s'ils voulaient quand j'ai
adhéré au front national je n'ai pas
adhéré pour jean marie le pen j'avais à
gré pour marine le pen comprenez-moi fin
j'ai jamais eu
de d'aprioris sur jean-marie c'était une
personnalité que j'appréciais ce qui
vous plaît pas c'est quoi ce qu'il soit
mis à l'écart que les choses se soient
faits en fait les choses se sont
clairement dégradée au sein de l'équipe
dirigeante et ça c'est éclaboussé
surtout le tout le fonctionnement du
front national depuis l'éviction de
jean-marie le pen parce que ensuite on a
voulu virer les proches de jean marie le
pen dont philippe chevrier mais
maintenant on vire les proches des
proches de jean marie le pen et s'ils
continuent comme ça ils vont finir par
s'exclure eux mêmes donc il faut qu'il
fasse comme très attention vous évoquez
vous l'avez dit tout à l'heure ce
conflit aussi devant la justice donc ce
sera un peu difficile d'en parler ce
soir mais dans les grandes lignes
qu'est-ce qui vous oppose aujourd'hui à
cyril note le maire de mantes la ville
pour lequel vous avez travaillé vous
étiez son directeur de cabinet comme je
voulais dit il ya une
contentieux qui est en cours donc je
vais pas rentrer dans le détail je
conteste simplement
la manière
dont
a plus faim mes responsabilités
vous avez été écarté trop rapidement
j'écarte anglais la vie j'ai été écarté
j'ai quitté la collectivité et je
conteste la manière dont ça a été fait
finalement vous avez longtemps dénoncée
aussi des pratiques que vous avez jugées
douteuses au sein du ps au sein des
républicains de l'ump finalement au
front national aujourd'hui c'est la même
chose qui se produit j'ai jamais été
membre d'un autre parti donc je ne sais
pas comment fonctionne en interne vous
aviez un regard critique quant à eux sur
leurs fonctions oui oui bien sûr bien
sûr ben oui forcément force est de
constater que la façon dont est gérée
aujourd'hui le front national est à mes
yeux très inquiétants parce qu'il ya une
dérive
autoritariste
moi je fais le la distinction entre
l'autorité et l'autoritarisme
l'autorité elle se mérite si vous voulez
et l'autorité qui se mérite et qui met
en avant créer de la discipline d'accord
quand
d'enseignants autoritariste
il peut plus avoir cette discipline ça
se mérite vous dénoncez donc c'est ce
mode de fonctionnement au delà de ça est
ce que les idées aussi l'évolution des
idées vous gêne au front national les
idées qui sont défendues aujourd'hui
vous vous y retrouvez encore
jeu il ya une ou peut-être une évolution
sur certaines sur certains aspects
économiques sur certains aspects
sociétaux qui
sont pas forcément
ce que j'attends moi du du front
national maintenant
on verra ce qu'il ya dans le programme
de marine le pen on l'a pas encore fait
son programme donc on attend au moment
des élections par exemple vous pourriez
voter marine le pen au moment des
élections je pourrais ne pas voter
marine le pen vous pourriez ne pas voter
marine le pen sur cette question de
l'investiture justement vous avez évoqué
au début de cet entretien les
investitures vous avez demandé pour les
législatives que vous n'avez pas obtenu
est ce que finalement très clairement ce
n'est pas un peu de rancoeur aussi qui
s'exprime aujourd'hui
nous on a toujours de la rancoeur bien
quand on donne six ans de sa vie de
sakineh séquence en sachant les
sacrifices qui vont avec quentin front
national c'est pas évident on perdre des
amis on perd un des membres de sa
famille qui comprennent pas et c'est
donc qu'il ya déjà des sacrifices
personnels qui sont qui sont durs mais
on fait parce qu'on défende des
convictions quand on voit au bout de six
ans qu'on s'est battu pour ces idées là
et que aujourd'hui l'état-major du front
national tire dans le dos de leurs
soldats je pense qu'il ya un vrai
problème votre avenir en politique est
ce que vous serez candidat vous pouvez
imaginer le natif sous une autre
étiquette jeu je compte j'espère pouvoir
être candidat aux élections législatives
sur la 11e circonscription des yvelines
maintenant
il ya un financement à rechercher
évidemment
et c'est en cours en tout cas par
exemple avec philippe chevrier vous avez
encore des liens alors vous imaginez
jean marie le pen a évoqué aussi la
possibilité de lancer un autre mouvement
bien sûr avec avec philippe chevrier et
quelques autres amis nous avons créé un
cercle de réflexion think tank
qu'on appelle qu'on a appelé le front
libérer pour bien montrer qu'aujourd'hui
le front national n'est pas un front
national libre parce que quand on me
quand on me reproche un tweet ou
j'exprime une opinion sans nommer une
personne en particulier contester à
travers ce tweet zvonareva s'est emmêlé
décision qui a été pris par their
demande la ville mais moi j'ai exprimé
une opinion or on me reproche cette
opinion et on utilise ce prétexte pour
me mettre en commission de discipline
je rappelle quand même que le le droit
de lanfains l'opinion cédant même dans
la constitution française
bon après vous ont été exprimés contre
un membre aussi de votre parti avec qui
vous êtes déjà en conflit
j'ai le droit de contester une décision
enfin je me sens un homme libre si je
trouve qu'une décision de mauvaises je
me donne le droit de l'exprimer pour en
revenir à votre candidature cv parler de
ce oui donc nous devons libérer on a
créé voilà
cinq toques on espère qu'on a l'ambition
est d'en faire un parti politique
est
évidemment soutien de jean marie le pen
là et donc on espère pour avoir le
financement qui va avec pour pouvoir
financer des des candidats aux élections
législatives donc quelle que soit la
décision finalement du front national
sur votre sanction ou mal vous filtrez
le front national même si vous n'êtes
pas exclu du front national je veux dire
moi j'ai pas j'ai plus de scrupule par
rapport à leur attitude envers moi j'ai
pas de scrupules voilà des mois derniers
mois françois simeoni qu'est le
responsable actuel donc département lui
a déclaré que vous aviez été un
excellent militants et que vous étiez un
ami du camp national même si vous étiez
d'une autre sensibilité bien sûr il a
dit sur votre plateau la même chose à
propos de philippe chevrier que c'était
un excellent secrétaire départemental on
se demande pourquoi on nous vire
finalement puisqu'on était excellent bon
il dit après simplement faut changer de
me faire des nouvelles mettent des
nouvelles têtes ça qui l'a dit une serre
nouvellement renouvellement des cadres
renouvellement des cadres et où bon lui
les cadres aussi depuis huit ans
peut-être qu'il faudrait aussi le
renouveler lui par contre
je crois que c'est vraiment une grosse
hypocrisie de sa part parce que
parce que c'est françois simioni
via un courriel que je me suis procuré à
caen expliqué à l'ensemble du bureau des
yvelines que ma commission que ma
convocation à la leçon de discipline
était dû à mon contentieux
avec le maire demande très bien pas
écouté on le fera on le fera réagir sur
cette cette affirmation ou nous donner
ce soir merci nicolas bauer en tout cas
d'être venu je rappelle que vous êtes
élue dans l'opposition à elancourt est
en attente donc de ce jugement cette
verdict de la commission de discipline
du front national merci à vous toutes
autres sujets c'est une problématique de
plus en plus pressante pour les communes
comment soutenir le commerce de
proximité et il ya cette opération au
fait du commerce qui se tenait la
semaine dernière dans la plupart des
communes de france et notamment à
maurepas nous avons rencontré son maire
grégory cariste et qui nous explique
comment il compte organiser sa commune
s'est développé ces services de
proximité face aux grandes enseignes
l'idée étant de favoriser nos commerces
locaux comme vous le disiez avec aussi
la concurrence qui existe avec les
grands ensembles commerciaux et je suis
le premier d'ailleurs à pouvoir le dire
puisque je suis au niveau de
l'agglomération vice président chargé de
la stratégie commerciale entre 50 quand
même qu'à une complémentarité avec les
grands dossiers commerciaux et le
commerce local malgré tout le commerce
local doit être soutenue avec de
nombreuses actions c'est aussi
l'idée d'un vrai lien social entre les
habitants et les commerces et c'est pour
ça qu'il ya diverses actions qui sont
développés au travers ces jeunes et de
commerces de proximité
mais il faut aussi essayer de faire
toute l'année mais en tout cas la
journée de commerce de proximité à la
lune nationalement et c'est l'idée de
faire exister justement est de porter ce
message aux efforts l'occasion de cette
journée de proximité avec une vraie
volonté politique comme vous deviez
aussi avec des modes de consommation ont
changé donc là aussi les clients où je
veux dire les habitants ont un vrai rôle
à apporter et s'ils préfèrent consommer
dans les grands dossiers de conversion
voilà c'est aussi le rôle d'une
municipalité et des commerçants des
associations de commerçants avec
lesquels nous travaillons évidemment en
lien est fortement de faire comprendre
que le commerce local est indispensable
notamment on a aussi des populations qui
vieillissent et sa population qui
vieillit son besoin d'avoir accès à leur
commerce directement parce que les
moyens de transport sont pas forcément
là et comme je le disais tout à l'heure
c'est un lien aussi de dynamisme de un
lien social encore tout à l'heure il y
avait une boulangerie la brûlure jo
woerth qui a mis à disposition un stand
pour faire connaître ses produits puis
avait une une dame assez âgées qui
venait chercher quelques gaufres et
qu'ils discutaient avec la boulangère et
justement ça permet aussi de tisser cc
c'est bien utile dans la vie d'une
communauté et je pense que ça doit être
donc un message aux efforts que les
maires doivent porter une équipe
municipale doit porter en
complémentarité avec ce qui se peut se
faire en tout cas dans les anciens
commerciaux une dernière question du cru
jusque maurepas et fortement mobilisé
son sujet est-ce que vous vous sentez
vous depuis que vous êtes à l'amérique
je la façon de consommer peu changé chez
les norvégiens et est ce que vous sentez
une évolution que c'est aussi un sujet
qui les concerne les morlaisiens même je
sens une forte attente puisque moi-même
je reçois des messages de mort patients
qui me disent qu'ils sont évidemment
attaché alors leur commerce local
d'autant plus que quand vous avez des
cellules qui sont vides où vous avez des
commerces qui s'en vont les mortuaciens
s'adresse directement mer alors que j'ai
pas forcément la main dans le sens où ce
sont des activités privées et donc le
rôle d'une municipalité c'est
d'accompagner décidé de renouveler en
tout cas les activités de faire en sorte
de savoir qui est propriétaire des murs
qui est propriétaire des fonds qui est
propriétaire des baux pour accompagner
c'est le cas par exemple de notre
libraire qui connaît des difficultés en
ce moment qu'à trouver maintenant un
nouveau propriétaire et qui va pouvoir
se relancer dans les mois qui viennent
avec une activité diversifiée et là je
remercie vraiment l'ensemble des
commerces quand participer il y en a
plus de 21 qui partit à cette journée de
commerce de proximité les commerçants du
marché aussi que j'ai vu ce matin qui
organise également une tombola où un
certain nombre de d'action justement
pour faire connaître leurs produits
parce que justement et je sens cette
cette dimension locale qui revient et
auquel maintenant les habitants sont
attachés on revient via mon valeurs
d'autrefois
c'est la fin du set 8 les invités on se
retrouve lundi très bon week end
[Musique]